- [Narrator] If you've
ever shopped at Costco
you may have noticed that
it's a little different.
- Costco is not engineered
for a quick shopping trip.
It is exactly the opposite.
- [Narrator] This is
the economics of Costco.
- It's not a grocery store.
It's not a small corner store.
It's huge, it's cavernous.
The ceiling is high.
Goods are literally stacked
on pallets up to the,
almost the ceiling.
That's all part of the
model and the experience.
- I got a Costco hall.
The first think we got
is a five dozen of eggs.
Then we've got salmon...
- [Narrator] Unlike most
stores, there are no aisle signs
or in store maps to help direct shoppers.
Instead aisles are simply numbered.
What's more Costco, constantly moves some
of its products and
cycles in new products.
So what gives?
Why are Costco stores designed this way
and how has it helped the company grow
into the retail behemoth that it is today?
- Costco is a big fan of
using treasure hunt retail
psychology to draw you in,
which is basically having items
on the shelf that are at a like wow price
because there's such a good discount
or they're just really interesting
and they're not gonna be there forever.
- [Narrator] The big idea behind Costco's
treasure hunt strategy is
that by encouraging customers
to explore and ensuring that
there's always a new batch
of interesting deals, customers
end up shopping longer
and buying more products.
- [Woman] Today, I went to
Costco thinking I was just gonna
get a few items, but I ended
up with the whole entire cart.
- When you go into the store,
it doesn't feel the same
as the last time you were there.
And so you have a sense of
urgency about purchasing
and also just a sense
of wanting to come back,
right and check out what's going on.
If it was the same, every time
you might not come as often.
- [Narrator] Today, Costco
is one of the world's largest
retailers boasting over 803
locations and 275,000 employees.
- Costco was part of sort
of this early warehouse club
concept which was really
about, instead of like
go to the store buy a single item,
come to the store, pay membership
and maybe you're a small business
and we'll offer you wholesale prices,
basically lower prices.
- [Narrator] Most members
pay an annual fee of $60
for the basic plan.
The customers can upgrade
to the executive membership
which is more perks for $120 a year.
Membership dues are also how
Costco makes most of its money.
- I think Costco's management's main goal
is always this ethos of, can
we offer more exciting items
at a better price to
keep memberships growing?
The model is make money on the membership,
sell things as cheaply as possible.
They can't just raise
the price on something
to increase the profit that's
against the internal code.
And so that also includes
things like let's save money
in how much time we spend
putting products on shelves.
So that's part of the reason
why you see these pallets
of goods stacked up to the
ceiling is there's not a lot
of time spent taking apart those pallets,
putting each individual
product on the shelf.
If they eliminate that
there's a little bit
of labor savings,
there's some time savings
because they're just putting
all that stuff out on a pallet
and you take it.
- [Narrator] Costco says
that an average item
in the store is only marked
up 11% compared to the 25
to 50% often seen in retail.
This commitment to low prices
hasn't just kept customers
loyal, it has also helps spread the brand.
- There's a psychology to finding a deal
that's very satisfying for people
and people enjoy the
product selection at Costco.
They have very skilled
merchants that usually
have been employed there
for a very long time
and really know what a Costco
customer likely would want.
And they're good at getting
good prices on those products.
- I got premier protein flavor vanilla.
- And that sort of
creates a certain frenzy
around finding those things.
- I got the Kirkland
brand microwave popcorn.
I got two packs of bottled water.
- [Narrator] Most retailers might assume
that shoppers want more choices, not less.
- They sell a limited number of items.
So that means they have
to be pretty precise.
They think about like
giving space to a product
in their store differently
than a Walmart would.
And if that product doesn't sell
like it's out of there,
it's very cutthroat.
If you're a product on the shelf
you have to earn your place.
- [Narrator] The average Costco warehouse
stock's about 3,700
products at any given time.
Less than 1/10 of most
supermarkets, 40 to 50,000 items.
But even though Costco stocks fewer items
the items they do stock have a reputation.
- I see you've notice me
rolling up the sleeves
on my new Kirkland signature quarters
that my mother got me for the holidays.
- Kirkland is Costco's you
know, private label brand.
It's their store brand.
It's a brand that when
they wanna offer something
at a certain price they don't
feel a manufacturer supplier
can do it.
They build it themselves
- [Narrator] Since it was launched in 1995
the in-house brand has built a reputation
for quality and low
prices on everyday items.
Today. Kirkland products make up a quarter
of Costco's $166 billion in annual sales.
- But when you talk to customers,
I think they generally feel
that it doesn't necessarily
need to be fancy because
they've already bought
into this Costco pitch which
is, this is high quality
and it's a lower price and you don't need
to be afraid of it.
- [Narrator] That customer
loyalty helped Costco
remain strong during the pandemic.
- Costco is certainly a
model that has not only
survived the pandemic
but has really thrived
in the pandemic.
- [Narrator] Despite
the increased popularity
of online shopping Costco
has leaned into its strategy
of driving members to it stores.
- It's really interesting
to me because for years,
people have questioned Costco.
You know, Amazon is gonna get you.
You got to get bigger online
and that really hasn't played
out yet.
They've said explicitly,
we prefer people to come
into the store and shop.
We want impulse buys.
We want people to come in and
see what we have and buy more.
We work better that way and it's cheaper.
(soft music)